[Music]
stilton is a creamy and crumbly british
blue cheese whose roots date back to the
early 1700s
it tastes mellower and less salty than
many other varieties of blue cheese
always produced in an 18 pound cylinder
format it has veins of blue mold
radiating from the center outward
the production of stilton is strictly
regulated
only half a dozen dairies in the world
located in three specific english
counties are licensed to produce it
and only from locally produced
pasteurized milk
it takes 20 gallons of milk to make each
18-pound cylinder of stilton
they begin by pouring milk in a vat
next they add starter culture
laboratory-grown natural organisms
then they mix a blue mold culture called
penicillium roquefort with distilled
water and add this to the milk as well
after about three hours they stir in
rennet enzymes that coagulate the milk
fat
after about 90 minutes workers run a
wire knife through the now gelatinous
milk separating the fat called curds
from the liquid called whey
then overnight they drain the way out of
the bottom of the vat
the next morning the firm curds go
through a mill which breaks them up into
a crumbly consistency
workers weigh out portions of 24 pounds
each of which will become an 18 pound
cylinder of cheese
after adding salt the company won't
disclose just how much two workers
gently hand mix the portion
two different mixing styles blending the
ingredients more thoroughly than one
then they funnel each portion into a
cylindrical plastic cheese mold called a
hoop
the curds still contain whey so workers
stack the hoops for five days
typically cheeses are pressed to drain
the whey not stilton
here gravity does the job the cheese
drains under its own weight workers flip
the hoop once daily to drain through
both the top and bottom
after five days they remove the hoop
the cheese now dryer stands on its own
while with a knife they perform a
critical procedure called rubbing up
they rub the entire surface with a flat
blade sealing all the holes so that air
can't penetrate and cause premature
internal mold growth
now the cheese goes onto a stillage a
type of trolley and begins its journey
through the climate-controlled blueing
rooms named for the color of the
internal mold growth which occurs there
workers flip the cheese daily to prevent
its cylindrical shape from distorting
under its own weight
within a week to 10 days grayish white
sometimes orange naturally occurring
mold begins growing on the outside
and from that point on when the cheese
acquires a certain amount of mold they
move it to the next level room then to
the next one and so on
at about the five week mark they mount
the cheese on the turntable of a
piercing machine
with each press of a foot pedal the
turntable rotates slightly
and long stainless steel needles pierce
the cheese
[Music]
these tiny holes permit oxygen to enter
and kick start the penicillin roquefort
blue mold culture that the dairy put in
the milk earlier on
before long blue mold gradually grows
from the center of the cheese outward
to monitor the extent of the blue mold
growth
the dairies cheese graters draw samples
using a tool called a cheese iron
the iron reaches all the way to the core
of the cylinder
when the sample shows that the bluing
runs right through the cheese is ready
more or less
the timing is actually a bit tricky
stilton is a relatively young cheese
best eaten between 12 and 14 weeks
the dairy does its best to coordinate
shipping so that the cheese is at its
optimum quality when it reaches the
customer
therefore it ships eight or nine week
old cheese to local stores
and seven week old cheese to
international customers so that the blue
stilton will be an ideal eight or nine
weeks of age when it arrives at its
destination
[Music]
you